mort de cette fine kubicki aujourd'hui
voit tout ce qui se passe et ne réagit
pas j'en ai marre de voir tous ces
politiques se gargariser au sens de
l'assemblée nationale et de ne pas réagi
astuces passe en france ça devient
regrettable vous avez ici la caisse davo
de l'allemand kinoïtes nominativement
nous interdit d'aller à droite ou à
gauche on est dans un pays rivaux qui
s'appelle la france
si monsieur l'allemande ne te souviens
plus de ses cours d'éducation civique
qu'il retourne à l'école le groupe salue
sera grande et un accord votre
aujourd'hui je suis dans un pays libre
j'irai là où on me semble il pourra me
mettre toutes les armes anti feu la
semaine dernière ils ont gagné 55 euros
le monsieur l'allemand et moi j'ai
acheté un sac ou plus gros des moyens le
long puisque sur l'autoritarisme
capitaliste qui veut nous imposer sur
paris mais non on puisse nouvelle
approche de repartir
bon
[Musique]
sachez qu'il avait créée que l'on joue
pour appliquer des lois liberticides
j'en veux pas la pollution
j'en veux à la mac reviennent jean-paul
à castanet réel et à l'allemande
les espèces qui y est qui se cache
derrière croissant fut pour les flux en
france et je le rêve n'aura pas du jour
300 les gars quoi qu'il arrive en
découdra en réponse de votre
responsabilité sur toute l'année fait
preuve et des dieux qui a dit en marge
de la déco de gama qui perdent leur vie
à eux ne vous les voulez nous avons de
la vie aucun document ma guérison pour
l'arrêter rocard donc aujourd'hui c'est
une reine et où sont généralement ma
carte d'identité je ne l'aurais plus
entre les mains est terminée vous avez
ces capteurs de maman de la semaine
dernière sans aucun document officiel
lors d'une fête
[Musique]